so perhaps this is a good uh time for me
to explain what I mean by Elite
overproduction
yeah yeah please it's an important idea
in your book
um so let's break it down first like
what the heck do you mean by Elite
exactly who are the elites um simply put
um it's a neutral thing it's not good
people bad people it's simply a small
proportion of the population that
concentrates Social Power in their hands
so think about the preferable one
percent in America oh it's it's a little
bit more complicated than that but also
you know Mandarin class in Imperial
China or if you go back into the past
military and ability in England France
so these are people with power
and the next question you want to ask
about Elite is the Dynamics of it
oh are they reproduced and recruited
that's the key question there's always
more people who want to be in to acquire
Elite positions the positions of power
so we call such uh Elite one ABS Elite
aspirants all right and that's normal
and some competition is good however
sometimes in societies
um the number of elite aspirants begins
to grow rapidly in completely overwhelms
the number of power positions we saw
this happen in 2016 when there were 17
Republican candidates in the
presidential primaries and there is
about one individual started breaking
rules and it was followed by others and
very soon things they generated into
something that nobody here expected but
that's a normal outcome you see this in
medieval societies we see this in
periods preceding such
um you know breakdowns like French and
Russian revolutions American Civil War
is another example in all the run-ups to
this huge crisis there was a various
severe a problem of elite overproduction
and that is what led to the breakdown of
social norms and eventually it led to
Bloodshed so you have a very compelling
uh picture of what comes next there's
something called the political stress
index that uses some of these variables
and says that we're now at a higher
level of political stress than at any
time since uh the first Civil War or the
only civil war we hope it's the only
civil war and in your book
end times you talk about what you think
is coming now uh according to the data
and the model so if you had to describe
to someone what you think is coming next
what what do the next number of years
hold in store first of all I want to
make a comment that getting into crisis
it's like a ball rolling down a narrow
Valley so there's no really no place to
go which is why I was fairly confident
about making prediction back in 2010 but
once you get to the crisis
um you are on the cusp and all kinds of
avenues open the social system has quite
a lot of inertia so now that we are in a
crisis what we we can do is
negotiate or navigate a way out that is
going to be less bloody than uh what's
actually possible to happen many people
look at the summer of 2020 well
including January 2021 and think that
okay this is a spike now we are past the
worst but what our historical analysis
shows is that typically these periods
run of civil disturbance and high
political violence they typically Run 10
to 20 years all right sometimes very few
examples shorter sometimes if you have
complete collapse then essentially it's
until something new comes around so a
turbulent 10 to 20 years makes sense to
me intuitively if that's the historical
pattern I I am now trying to put forward
a more positive brand of politics that
gets beyond the two-party back and forth
that I think is going to be kind of the
flash point for a lot of this turbulence
uh you know it's going to be animating
um the hostility in various ways now
there are a bunch of Common Sense things
I think uh you'd want
us to be doing and so if you had to just
make a you know a couple of policy
recommendations that you think hey
either before during or after uh the
this uh turbulent period like this is
what's gonna bring us back together uh
like what does that list look like well
I'm I'm not going to make specific
policy recommendations let me explain we
do have uh several positive examples and
one of them you mentioned it's uh United
States during the Progressive and then
you deal era it turns out if you look at
the data that 1920 or so there was a
huge Peak plus minus several years a
huge peak of instability in the United
States which was quite similar to 1850s
but this time around the elites managed
to avoid another civil war that the New
Deal did what they did well first of all
they gave power to workers to organize
and negotiate they imposed meaning
minimum wage which kept and it kept
increasing it and also they taxed the
hell out of people with high incomes
so we don't have to do exactly the same
thing what we need to do we need to shut
down this wealth pump so we need to get
uh worker wages back on track together
with the general economy
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you